ces techniciens de l'événementiel
n'avait pas retravaillé depuis le mois
de mars hier soir à cour cheverny
ils ont retrouvé l'ambiance des tournées
le temps d'un concert
même sans public on retrouve un peu
l'ambiance bat des spectacles est tous
des soirées ou des choses qu'on a pu
faire le con on appelle ça le
l'adrénaline du show qui va commencer
des petites et petites galères de
dernière minute qu'il faut raisonner et
c'est certain la course est toujours
c'est ce qu'on aime aussi dans ce métier
la fierté surtout et ses amis en live et
go du risque passe pendant une heure
n'hésitez pas à partager soleil parce
que ça va ici ce soir les amis c'est
pascal rey patron d'audio espace
spécialisé dans l'événementiel qui a
lancé l'idée de ces captations diffusé
en streaming depuis son labo une petite
bouffée d'oxygène alors que pour lui
l'année 2000 21 ans s'annoncent très mal
toutes les dates de concerts ont été
annulés il ya beaucoup trop
d'incertitudes
on voit pas le bout du tunnel et on n'a
pas vraiment d'informations de la part
de l'état de ce qui va se passer donc
l'opportunité d'avoir fait cette ce
studio c'est vraiment de s'éclater et
d'essayer de faire des choses et
et voilà pour aussi bien pour les
artistes que pour nous c'est super
important
tous les mercredis et vendredis soirs
jusqu'au mois de mars
un artiste va pouvoir diffuser son
concert en direct sur les réseaux
sociaux une opportunité pour des jeunes
comme antoine garrel dj et
percussionniste tourangeau acquis la
scène commençait vraiment à manquer
c'est forcément un petit peu différent
mais je dirais que la bonne petite
pression la petite dose d'adrénaline que
tous les artistes rond elle est présente
elle est différente c'est vrai que sur
un concert ou voient les gens en vrai on
voit les sourires on voit souvent la
bienveillance ça fait plaisir
là les sourires plus aujourd'hui sont
masqués mais l'équipe était là j'ai
partagé avec eux c'était très sympa et
j'espère que tout le monde a apprécié
depuis son écran ordinateur pour ces
captations techniciens et artistes sont
tous bénévoles
une cagnotte a été ouverte pour financer
au moins les dépenses d'électricité
d'eau dues aux espaces mais l'idée est
surtout de s'amuser à nouveau de rire et
de danser